go ahead and shoot go ahead and shoot
I'll have your whole I'll have your
house I'll have your whole [__]
house I'll make your mom my [__] little
[__] something like
[Music]
that so imagine you're a door Dash
delivery
driver um and you're delivering in
Virginia and then all of a sudden
there's an 11-year-old kid with a gun
and they carjack you oh [__] oh [__]
yeah that's got carjacked by 11year old
that's what happened to Dion Smith
that's why you got to move to Vegas man
bro always goes back to you can't be in
Virginia like that dude so she was
making a delivery to an apartment
complex after midnight November 30th she
was just dropping off some McDonald's or
something M I bet the 11-year-old don't
look 11 though yeah I blame GTA dude no
don't ever blame g GTA is amazing GTA is
awesome dude six is coming out in a
couple of years you better not mess that
up for is coming out next2 yeah 2025
thank you we got to watch the trailer as
a
squ but honestly though child soldiers
are like they're kind of scary though
they're the craziest they're they're the
most wild how'd they get here no they're
just everywhere how they get here I
thought they were only like in other
countries that are like War torn how
they how how come it happened here con
sent them to us they they'll have kids
and they'll make them do all these crazy
[__] where they're like yo go shoot that
[__] and we'll just go do it
statistically kids with armed kids under
the age of 14 are more likely to shoot
during a robbery than someone over 30
cuz they're stupid yeah so self Deion
Smith is walking outside she gets
approached by two people the little one
comes up first and he and you know she's
like okay he's going to ask me for money
or something like that but then I
realized holy [__] he's asking me for my
keys while he's pointing a gun at me and
then she tried to to deescalate with the
kid who she later Learned was 11 um he
said he when he told me or she she said
when he told me he was going to shoot me
I was like are you serious you want to
kill somebody at your age I was asking
where's your mom why are you out here
this time of night made him more mad huh
and he said ma'am I'm 11 years old do
you think my do you think I would be
alone here I don't think so no [__]
way
no is a season for home alone quot
though I don't think so I don't think so
I love that sh
so she had kept her she kept her she
kept her car running uh as she made the
delivery and then the older suspect got
in the driver's seat and called out for
the kid to get in and then they took off
oh [__] that's the best way man just
[__] it take the keys we'll figure it
out later but at least you're alive yeah
damn dude is there a part of you that
goes like I can take this [__] kid
dude you got Jack your CH a kid with a
gun feels more dangerous than an adult
with a gun for sure but like you know
the Detroit urban survival that could
work on 11year Old it'll probably it's
more likely to work on 11-year-old than
a [__] uh
22-year-old you know what I mean think
about it the
newspaper Detroit urban survival yeah
well you guys remember Superman from um
the old old show the black and white
show Superman from black and white show
George Reeves he was like George Reeves
I don't remember that when you see like
Superman
classic um this
guy oh [__] oh wow one that got
paralyzed right that's even before
Christopher so so this is George Reeves
yeah oh [__] he um he was at a an event
being Superman like where they did like
like an outdoor like theatrical show
basically where he comes in and like
there's a bunch of like basically it's
like the har glob TRS versus the
Washington generals and he like schools
all these robbers and it's all big act
and [__] he like bends a bar in half and
breaks a gun and [__] well a kid had
come to the show with a real gun and he
like basically came out like from the
audience he points the gun at George
Reeves and he's basically like like um
hey if I if I can I shoot you oh like he
thought that he's Superman super oh [__]
he's like can I shoot you and then like
George Reeves is like hey look man like
if you know what if it bounces off of me
and hurt somebody oh that's tricky right
wow yeah and then George Reeves ended up
having to kill the kid that's dope how
do you do it you laser
ass he used cold breath he sucked the
[__] out of and then made him fall in a
million pieces yeah flick he flew around
the world reverse time and the kid was
never born oh damn that's a good one god
dude that's that crazy holy [__] what a
dumb kid yeah what a stupid kid so he's
like I didn't think about that part I
might have heard an audience member
that's really his response that's pretty
smart he's really smart right State
character I think the real issue is how
are these kids getting guns well that
was in like the 60s right yeah his dad
probably had it on a [__] coffee
table right next to the cigar and
whiskey lior yeah yeah but that's like
that's a struggle imagine you you're
like rid in between I don't want to get
shot and also I don't want to screw the
brand up yeah Fu [__] that dude cuz it's
like a public those things were big back
then those like public events that were
spectacles and meant to like advertise
they did that for Zoro and like all
those old shows even I of Lucy they they
they go in the middle of those things
cuz they happen so often right but
that's crazy to like have to think of
like what would Mickey Mouse say like he
buddy watch
out I'm basically a control of the world
you little
[__] go ahead and shoot go ahead and
shoot I'll have your whole [__] I'll
have your house I'll have your whole
[__]
house I'll make your mom my [__] little
[__] something like that something like
that yeah damn damn that's [__] scary
yeah how do you deal with a kid with a
gun kid yeah ta pulled a gun off you
you're one of your guns yeah he's like
hey Daddy have like if you just found it
one day and he was like Dad look oh no
he already knows not to touch yeah he
already knows if there's a gun never
touch it immediately tell me or his mom
um and just he's like even if a bad guy
I was like what happens if a bad guy
comes and robs the house and drops the
gun do you pick up the gun he's like
nope just leave it right where it is so
he knows like if any gun he just leaves
it and comes and tells what if you catch
him in the middle of his rebellious
seven-year-old phase where he's like
listening to rap and [__] yeah sideways
busting caps in the house he's doing
live streams and he's like pointing at
the screen yeah yeah with other NBA
players so you're saying what could have
prevented this kid from having a gun is
just good
parenting probably I like the way you
say that that's a good I never thought
about that it's like it's so obvious
obious right but then it's crazy how one
thing a parent doesn't do leads to like
your kids doing all so in the scope of
good parenting if Tao were to still make
the mistake of like messing that up and
and like he's holding your gun playing
with it what's the punishment for
that dude that's tough the like he knows
it's wrong but he still did it he has to
hold 10 guns like
[Laughter]
this 10 minutes that's good oh you want
to touch a gun huh yeah yeah and he has
the whole 10 [__] guns
10 I might just have to [__] like
super glue [__] gun you like guns
that much huh oh you pointed at him
super you just have to have guns in his
hand so you just have to SP the whole
wasn't there a movie like that with a
[__] Harry you're getting
scho oh my God such a funny punishment
cuz that's hard like imagine having to
reinforce it and like no now you really
have to not mess up after making the
mistake once cuz you know kids are still
going to screw that's like when their
parents found us with cigarettes and you
go all right you like cigarettes here's
a [__] carton yeah yeah you got to
you got to like the same lessons you got
to tell them like 10,000 times you're so
[__] stupid yeah right for sure over
and over and over over until you're an
adult almost and his ADD is so bad like
he [__] forgets [__] like literally
something he just learned He he'll
forget he's sad like one time I forgot
what happened like he was like he was
crying go like like sobbing right and he
go he go I need to hug oh what happened
and he hugs
me and he touches my nipples he's
like what the I like did you just forget
you were
sad and he goes sobbing again he's a
lunatic yeah he's he's the joker I'm
like this is [__] crazy aren all kids
crazy though get out of here dude that's
a normal kid thing though that's funny
if he's like no I thought you told
sh with the
guns my bad dad I'm tripping damn dude I
was me and my neighbor were outside like
and he had his gun it was all like
cleared and everything but his Bulldog
was outside and his Bulldog ran out of
nowhere and started barking at the gun W
yeah and he had never trained his dog
about the guns or anything like that but
he didn't like the gun why dog didn't
like the gun you know some guns like are
some dogs they just they don't even like
gun sounds like sometimes I like you
know I'm clearing in my gun or I'm like
cleaning and you go and the dogs just be
like he's back away he just don't like
thatal sounds like
Keys it was kind of cool though I was
like this is kind of sick like having a
guard dog like that hell yeah that's
helpful cuz if he's like barking at a at
a gun then maybe there's like a gun in
the house or whatever that's I like
guard dogs but how do you train them not
to bite friends that's hard that's true
see you have to take them to school
maybe my buddy Richard has a bunch of uh
German Shepherds that were military
trained that's tight and they're like
$30,000 a piece yeah those things are
sick and he's like he yells German at
the dog because it was trained in
Germany and that they ship him Hereafter
yeah and it's fully trained it can do
anything it can like bartend thing's
[__] crazy flare flare
bartend yeah it's like it's like
ridiculous what these things can do
[__] limes dude when you're when
you're hanging out with your with your
Jewish friends do they go always feel
uncomfortable and stu oh yeah cuz he's
[Music]
going
pap